welcome back so we've been talking about
the sensitivity and complementary
sensitivity functions and the loop
transfer function and what we want these
different transfer functions to look
like for good compensation and model
uncertainty disturbance rejection noise
attenuation reference tracking and so on
and so forth okay but I said that the
sensitivity function gives us a direct
measure of the robustness of our system
and I also said that if I have a big
peak in the magnitude of s that's bad
for robustness so this is kind of a
cartoon at this point but I want to give
you an idea of why this is the case so
this is actually a relatively deep and
kind of complicated theory in transfer
functions and control theory and it's
built on a lot of background material
which I am NOT going to tell you about
so some of the background material is
the Nyquist stability criteria and this
goes way back before people were really
using state space ordinary differential
equation models back when people we're
only using transfer function models or
exclusive almost exclusively Nyquist
came up with stability criteria of what
K and P would look like when the system
goes unstable so he characterized
criteria for when the system is about to
blow up and become kind of non robust or
you know or unstable and so we're going
to kind of take for granted or use this
Nyquist stability criteria in the
derivation that of showing that s is
related to robustness and I'm going to
give you a little cartoon that gives
some insight into this okay because it's
kind of intuitively what we would think
so the idea is that I want my loop
transfer function to be as far away from
the point negative one in the complex
plane as possible for all frequencies so
I'll write this out and I'll draw some
pictures but basically if I take we draw
some colors here so if I take the
complex plane
see and I identify the point negative
one and let's say that my transfer
function if I plot if I literally take L
my loop transfer function and evaluate
it at I Omega and I plug in all the I
omegas on the entire imaginary axis so I
kind of take the bode plot if you will
the frequency response of L and I plot
the real and imaginary part in the
complex plane sometimes it'll I don't
know I'm not really good at drawing is
but it'll look like something and the
closer it gets to negative 1 the less
robust that system will be when I close
the loop so I'm just telling you this is
a fact I'll give you some intuition for
this in a minute but if I plot L of I
Omega this distance from this negative
one point is essentially my robustness
my stability margin for this system so
if I close the loop ok then this system
will go unstable if I increase K enough
that this passes through the point
negative 1 so remember if I just
increased K by a factor of 2 these value
should kind of grow okay and so if I
increase the the gain K on my controller
I'll essentially get this this loop
transfer function growing until
eventually it'll pass through the
negative 1 point and the system will go
unstable similarly if my plant model P
was twice as big as I think it you know
if they're true system is twice as big
of a P as my model and that would cause
my L to be bigger and it might pass
through this negative one point and go
unstable and blow up so this is kind of
my robustness margin the farther I am
away from this negative 1 point the more
robust my system is you can also see
that there are some phase information so
if I add some phase to my if I add some
phase to my system so let's say there's
a time delay here what that's
essentially going to do is it's going to
take my leap transfer function and kind
of rotate it and it might be that when I
rotate it at some point a point on this
curve
or we'll pass through this negative one
point and go unstable now why is this
negative one point so special we can
draw a kind of a simplified version of
this diagram where we just have
reference controller plant and why okay
it's a little faint and if I subtract
that I get my little epsilon and I have
my U and so the idea is I can write my
transfer function y2 r I can write this
as y equals and I think it's something
like PK over 1 plus PK now I'm drawing
this for a single input single
dimensional use single output single
dimensional Y system so this is just I
can do these divisions and now you can
see that it does PK if my loop transfer
function equals negative 1 if PK equal
negative 1 if my loop transfer function
L passes through negative 1 boom the
system blows up at that frequency okay
so at whatever frequency right this is
parameterized by frequency Omega and if
I increase the gain K so that this
passes through negative 1 boom the
system immediately goes unstable
okay now I'm glossing over a ton of
stuff I'm not stating this terribly
precisely if you want to know exactly
the mathematical formulation you should
read about the Nyquist stability
criteria and there's deep theory about
how this robustness actually is
formulated in terms of this radius for
my leap transfer function but the
takeaways are the farther my loop
transfer function is from the negative
one point in the complex plane remember
if I take my loop transfer function and
evaluate it at I Omega for all
frequencies on the imaginary axis I
sweep out this curve the farther that
curve is from negative 1 the more robust
my system is the more I can handle
unmodeled dynamics and P the more I can
increase
my gain K to get more performance the
more time delays so sometimes my control
logic is going to test some time delays
and how long it takes to compute the
control law maybe I'm actually doing
some complicated stuff in here and my
computer takes a millisecond well is a
millisecond enough to make my system
blow up sometimes if you have a really
non robust system small time delays can
make your system blow up but if I have a
robust system if I'm really far away
from this point negative one at all of
the the points of my leap transfer
function then I'm pretty robust to time
delays and model uncertainty and
increases in gain okay and the cool
thing is is that this minimum distance I
drew it actually so that the minimum
distance is kind of along the real axis
but I couldn't have it said that the
minimum distance let's call that M the
minimum distance okay this is very
closely related to the sensitivity
function okay so if I take a single
input single output system I'm going to
say s equals 1 over 1 plus my loop
transfer function now if ok so what I'm
trying to say is this is the closer that
L is to negative 1 the bigger s is that
simple ok the closer this is to negative
1 so if L close to negative 1 then s is
big right I get 1 divided by a really
really small number so the closer L is
to negative 1 the less robust my system
is the bigger s is at that frequency so
if I have a really non robust system if
I'm right up against this negative 1
point then my F function is going to
have some frequency where it gets really
really big because s is going to be 1
over epsilon is something really small L
is going to be close to negative 1 so
essentially what we have is that the
mass
X of s the max of the absolute value of
s over all frequencies is essentially a
measure of how far we are from this from
this point here and so there's a precise
way of formulating this I'll do that in
the next little segment but basically if
if our system is non robust if L is
close to negative ones at any frequency
then s is going to be really really big
so I'll have it I have peaks in s then
I'm essentially fundamentally non robust
so a lot of control design in robust
control is making L the loop transfer
have the desirable properties while
keeping the maximum of s pushed down as
far as possible
okay so we'll talk about how to do that
and we'll also talk about what the there
are some limits on how far I can push s
down on some cases if I have time delays
if I right half-plane zeros of the
transfer function things like that but
we'll get to that in a little bit thank
you